three five four thumb
hi
hi
I come to the wood this is Michael
because I don't want divorce we're
having this beautiful moment
and all of a sudden
Trish walks in
I have a present for you
oh boy
[Music]
Trish look at me like as a person who
could take her son from here
would have to be on a good fit with
Mike's mom so I brought her present
oh you bought me some flowers to plant
yes
well thank you Natalie how are you I'm
fine
I'm sorta
well I'm just disappointed in how this
all turned out I'm just going to tell
you right out you know I don't like the
way things came with you and Michael and
my question to you would be why would
you even do this to Michael
why did you do this
[Music]
Natalie hurt me she
she left me and uh I just kind of like
closed myself off the world
and my mom cannot move past the fact
of
the Broken Heart from her son
my mom is a tough woman she uh does
often speak her mind my mom's got
questions and it's just a matter of
whether we're going to get answers or
not
I'm sorry if you didn't forgive me I'm
sorry I just don't know why you would
pretend to love somebody so so much that
you come over here
you totally used Michael that's all you
did was use him to get to America
and then still out of the kindness of
his heart because he is such a kind guy
he still sends a thousand dollars to
your mom and helps her and I'm grateful
to Mike I'm telling you on the grateful
to him a lot and
I'm sorry I'm good with some helping
your mom because Michael is such a
kind-hearted go yes man but you you took
advantage of all of his kind-heartedness
when it come to you you played with
somebody else's heart somebody else's
emotions and the minute you felt like
you could run off you did
I want you to know that I was honest to
Michael and I came with right feelings
but the hell we went through with
Michael and what we experienced because
of how it work
didn't want anymore destroy myself
so I step away
[Music]
I believe whatever she's telling me is
not really the truth
[Music]